TUCKER CARLSON IS COMING UP NEXT
NEXT.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
YOU’VE BEEN PAYING ATTENTION
RECENTLY AND YOU PROBABLY HAVE,
YOU’VE LIKELY SENSED THAT
SOMETHING PROFOUND IS HAPPENING
TO THIS COUNTRY RIGHT NOW,
SOMETHING THAT COULD TRANSFORM
WHAT AMERICA IS.
YOU CAN FEEL IT HAPPENING.
OUR LEADERS DENY IT, OFFICIALS
ON BOTH SIDES REASSURED AS THEY
ARE NOT PLANNING WHOLESALE
CHANGES TO THE COUNTRY.
THEY’RE JUST TRYING TO FIX
SPECIFIC PROBLEMS.
A MAN WAS BRUTALIZED BY POLICE
OFFICERS IN MINNEAPOLIS.
ANOTHER MAN WAS SHOT TO DEATH IN
THE PARKING LOT OF WENDY’S.
THOSE THINGS ARE BAD, THEY ARE
TELLING US IN ABUSES LIKE THAT
OR WHAT THEY ARE FIGHTING
AGAINST.
THEY SAY WE NEED NEW LAWS, MORE
GOOD FAITH, MORE ATTENTION TO
INJUSTICE AND THAT SOUNDS RIGHT
TO MOST AMERICANS.
AMERICANS ARE DECENT PEOPLE.
THEY WANT TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
CERTAINLY REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS APPEAR TO BELIEVE ALL
OF THIS OR MAYBE THEY ARE SO
SCARED THEY PRETEND THEY BELIEVE
IT.
EITHER WAY, JUST YESTERDAY, THE
G.O.P. LEADERSHIP
ENTHUSIASTICALLY BACKED A
LAW ENFORCEMENT REFORM BILL,
THEY ARE PROUD OF THAT, THEY
SEEM TO THINK THAT RAINING AND
THE POLICE WILL FIX THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEMS AND PRETTY
SOON WE CAN ALL GET BACK TO
LIVING IN 2014 AGAIN.
REPUBLICANS APPEARED TO BELIEVE
THIS IS A POLICY DEBATE.
BUT DEMOCRATS KNOW BETTER THAN
THAT.
THEY DON’T LIE TO THEMSELVES FOR
THEY UNDERSTAND THERE IS A
REVOLUTION IN PROGRESS.
THE DEATH OF GEORGE FLOYD MAY
HAVE SPARKED WIDESPREAD SINCERE
OUTRAGE AND THEY MAY SHARE THAT
OUTRAGE BUT THEY ALSO KNOW THAT
WHAT IS HAPPENING NOW HAS VERY
LITTLE TO DO WITH GEORGE FLOYD
FOR PEOPLE LIKE HIM.
LIKE ALL REVOLUTIONS, THE POINT
IS TO DESTROY THE SYSTEM AND
REPLACE IT WITH SOMETHING NEW.
BUT REPLACE IT WITH WHAT?
THAT IS THE QUESTION THE REST OF
US SHOULD BE ASKING RIGHT NOW.
WE SHOULD KNOW WHAT’S COMING.
WE KNOW WE HAVE NOW MADE OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM HAS BEEN IN PLACE
FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS BASED ON A
VERY SIMPLE IDEA.
ALL PEOPLE ARE CREATED BY GOD
WITH EQUAL MORAL VALUE.
PERIOD.
EVERY ONE OF THEM.
FOR THAT REASON AND THAT REASON
ALONE, ALL AMERICANS ARE TREATED
EQUALLY UNDER THE LAWS OF THE
UNITED STATES.
IN THIS COUNTRY, WE JUDGE YOU
FOR WHAT YOU DO, NOT HOW YOU
WERE BORN.
THAT IDEA HAS BEEN THE DEFINING
PRINCIPLE OF AMERICA SINCE THE
18TH CENTURY.
IT’S THE MAIN REASON WE ARE THE
FAIREST SOCIETY IN THE WORLD.
IT’S THE REASON PEOPLE MOVE
HERE.
TO THE EXTENT THAT MATT AMERICA
HAS FAILED TO LIVE UP TO THAT
PRINCIPLE OF EQUALITY, WE ARE
ASHAMED OF IT.
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING WE
HAVE AND WE SHOULD DEFEND IT.
WE SHOULD PRACTICE IT.
NOW FOR THE FIRST TIME IN OUR
HISTORY, WE ARE WITNESSING A
BROAD AND POWERFUL ATTACK ON THE
PRINCIPLE OF EQUALITY.
DAILY TOLD THAT ALL PEOPLE ARE
NOT CREATED EQUAL, SOME
AMERICANS ARE GUILTY, SOME ARE
INNOCENT.
NOTHING CAN CHANGE THIS.
WAS ALL DETERMINED AT BIRTH.
ALL WE CAN DO IS RESPOND
ACCORDINGLY.
PEOPLE IN FAVORED GROUPS MUST BE
HELD TO ONE STANDARD AND THOSE
IN DISFAVORED GROUPS, THE MORE
THEY TAINTED ONES, MUST BE HELD
TO ANOTHER STANDARD.
MOSTLY FOR THE SAKE OF
FORMALITY, BUT WE MUST APPLY
THOSE LAWS IN VERY DIFFERENT
WAYS ACCORDING TO THE DNA AND
THE BACKGROUND OF THE ACCUSED.
THAT SOUNDS FAMILIAR, IT’S
BECAUSE THIS KIND OF SYSTEM WE
JUST DESCRIBED BASED ON HEREDITY
AND BLOOD GUILT HAS BEEN VERY
COMMON IN HISTORY.
WAS THE RULE IN FEUDAL EUROPE
AND A TOTALITARIAN REGIME ON
THAT CONTINENT MORE RECENTLY.
IS STILL IN PRACTICE AND PARTS
OF THE WORLD.
IN NORTH KOREA, CHILDREN ARE
SENT TO PRISON CAMPS FOR THE
SINS OF THEIR ANCESTORS AND
UNFORTUNATELY, WE HAVE SEEN THIS
HERE TOO.
YOU MAY HAVE WONDERED HOW
POLITICIANS COULD HAVE JUSTIFIED
PRACTICES AS PERVERSE AS SLAVERY
AND JIM CROW IN A COUNTRY WITH A
CONSTITUTION LIKE I WAS THE
ANSWER WAS SIMPLE, BY ARGUING
THAT NOT ALL PEOPLE ARE CREATED
EQUAL.
SOME HAD A LESSER MORAL VALUE
FROM BIRTH, THOSE PEOPLE CARRIED
THE STAIN OF SIN WITH THEM.
YOU WERE ALLOWED TO TREAT THEM
DIFFERENTLY BASED ON WHO THEY
WERE.
AT THE TIME, MANY UNDERSTOOD
THIS WAS A LIE, SLAVERY
PERSISTED FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS
BUT ALWAYS SOME IN HISTORY THAT
CONSIDERED AS EVIL MUCH IS
BECAUSE IT WAS ABUSIVE, WHICH IT
WAS, BUT BECAUSE THE EXISTENCE
OF IT VIOLATED THE CENTRAL
PRINCIPLE OF THIS COUNTRY, AND
THEY WERE RIGHT.
WHERE ARE THOSE PEOPLE NOW?
LOOK AROUND.
IS ANYONE EMPOWERED DEFENDING
ABSOLUTE EQUALITY UNDER THE LAW?
IF THERE WAS EVER A TIME TO
REMIND AMERICA THAT WE ALL HAVE
EQUAL VALUE UNDER GOD, THAT TIME
IS RIGHT NOW.
BUT NO, NO ONE IN CHARGE OF
SAYING THAT.
HOW LEADERS ARE COWARDS WHEN WE
NEED THEM TO BE BRAVE.
THEY ARE MODELED WHEN WE NEED
THEM TO THINK CLEARLY.
IT’S POSSIBLE THEY NO LONGER
EVEN BELIEVE IN EQUALITY.
40 YEARS AGO, THIS WAS A
MIDDLE-CLASS COUNTRY AND AS A
RESULT, AMERICA HAD STRONGLY
EGALITARIAN VALUES PRETTY PRETTY
MUCH EVERYONE USED COMMERCIAL
AIRPORTS AND ATE AT
McDONALD’S.
REMEMBER THAT?
PEOPLE TALKED WITHOUT IRONY AS
THEIR RIGHTS.
YOU COULDN’T PAY EXTRA TO JUMP
AT THE HEAD OF THE LINE AT
DISNEY WORLD.
THE IDEA THAT SOMEONE LIKE
JEFFREY EPSTEIN COULD BEAT US
EXTRACT BECAUSE HE WAS RICH
WOULD HAVE SHOCKED THEN AND
WOULD HAVE DEMANDED AN
INVESTIGATION INTO JUST HOW HE
DIED.
WHY?
BECAUSE AMERICANS HATED
CORRUPTION.
THEY SAW CORRUPTION AS AN
OFFENSE AGAINST EQUALITY.
THAT WAS 40 YEARS AGO.
THINGS ARE MOVING IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION EVER SINCE.
WE NOW ACCEPT ON THE CRITICAL
ACCLAIM THAT SOME PEOPLE DESERVE
BETTER TREATMENT BASED ON HOW
THEY WERE BORN AND SOME WERE
SPREAD THIS IS THE MOST
POISONOUS AND DESTRUCTIVE OF ALL
IDEAS.
OTHER NATIONS UNDERSTAND THAT.
RWANDA HAS MADE IT A CRIME TO
MAKE ETHNIC APPEALS GIVING
ELECTION TO PRACTICE IDENTITY
POLITICS BECAUSE THEY KNOW VERY
WELL WHERE THAT LEADS.
HE HAD IDENTITY POLITICS IS
ACCELERATING HERE.
SHOULDN’T SURPRISE YOU THAT MOST
OF THE PEOPLE PUSHING THIS
POISON ARE BENEFITING FROM IT.
THEY ARE USING THE RECENT CHAOS
TO CODIFY DANGEROUS TRENDS
ALREADY IN PROGRESS, A
PERMANENTLY UNEQUAL SOCIETY
WHERE THEY ARE ELEVATED IN
OTHERS.
WINNERS AND LOSERS PREORDAINED
BY LAW, THUS THE COUNTRY THEY
ARE WORKING TOWARDS.
THEY LECTURE YOU WITH MAXIMUM
SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS ABOUT HOW
THEY ARE DOING PRECISELY THE
OPPOSITE OF THAT.
>> NOBODY IS ABOVE THE LAW.
>> NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
>> NO PERSON IS ABOVE THE LAW.
>> NOBODY SHOULD BE ABOVE THE
LAW.
>> NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
>> Tucker: NO ONE IS ABOVE THE
LAW, THEY SCOLD, MEANING YOU
AREN’T.
THEY ADMIT THIS OUT LOUD, NOT
PRETENDING ANYMORE, THEY ARE
MOVING TO REPEAL PROPOSITION
209.
EXPLICITLY BANS RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION IN HIRING AND
EDUCATION.
DEMOCRATS IN CALIFORNIA ARE NOW
FIGHTING FOR DISCRIMINATION.
THIS IS NOT CONSIDERED STRANGE
IN 2,020, NO ONE EVEN MENTIONED,
THE SHERIFF OF KENTUCKY
ANNOUNCED PLANS TO BRING
UNIVERSAL HEALTH INSURANCE TO
THE STATE BUT NOT FOR ALL
CITIZENS.
JUST FOR PEOPLE WITH THE RIGHT
SKIN COLOR.
EVERYONE ELSE WOULD PAY BUT ONLY
CERTAIN ETHNIC GROUPS WOULD
BENEFIT.
STILL IN OFFICE TONIGHT AND NO
ONE HAS TRIED TO IMPEACH HIM FOR
SUGGESTING THIS BECAUSE IDEALS
LIKE THIS ARE EVERYWHERE NOW,
TOTALLY UNCHALLENGED.
THIS IS THE MOST DIVISIVE
POSSIBLE WAY TO RUN A COUNTRY.
YOU WANTED TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
YOUR CHILDREN WOULD HATE EACH
OTHER, HE WOULD HOLD THEM TO
DIFFERENT STANDARDS AND THEY
CERTAINLY WOULD.
THERE IS A REASON THAT RACIAL
TENSION IS RISING IN THIS
COUNTRY.
IS BY DESIGN.
THE RACE IS NOT THE ONLY
DIVIDING LINE.
THE CORONAVIRUS LOCKDOWNS HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH RACE OR WHITE
AND BLACK, THANK GOD.
QUARANTINES ARE INSTEAD
SCIENTIFIC, PURELY A MATTER OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
THAT’S WHAT THEY TOLD US AND WE
BELIEVE THEM.
WE SAT PASSIVELY AS THEY
DESTROYED OUR COUNTRY’S ECONOMY
AS THEY INDICTED AMERICANS WERE
TRYING TO MAKE A LIVING AND THEN
THE BLACK LIVES MATTER RIOTS
STARTED AND WE LEARNED IT WAS
ALL FAKE.
THE VERY SAME OFFICIALS WHO
THREATENED US WITH THE REST FOR
GOING OUTSIDE URGE THEIR OWN
VOTERS TO FLOOD THE STREETS, AND
THEY DATED, AND NO ONE WAS
PUNISHED.
HOW COULD THIS HAPPEN?
IT WAS SUCH A FLAGRANT DOUBLE
STANDARD, NOT EVEN RIGHT IN YOUR
FACE.
THEY DIDN’T TRY TO EXPLAIN IT,
THEY DIDN’T BOTHER TO JUSTIFY
IT.
WHY?
ANYONE FAMILIAR WITH
TOTALITARIAN REGIMES CAN TELL
YOU EXACTLY WHY.
THIS IS RITUAL HUMILIATION.
FORCING PEOPLE TO ACCEPT
MISTREATMENT IS A TIME-TESTED
WAY TO SUBDUE THEM.
OF COURSE WE ARE NOT TREATING
YOU FAIRLY, THEY ARE TELLING US.
YOU DON’T DESERVE FAIRNESS.
YOU DESERVE WHAT YOU GET.
THAT’S THE MESSAGE.
AND AFTER A WHILE, THE
POPULATION ACCEPTS THIS.
SOME BELIEVE IT.
THEY BLAME THEMSELVES.
THAT’S THE GOAL.
BUT WE SHOULD NEVER ACCEPT IT.
THE PROMISE OF ABSOLUTE EQUALITY
UNDER THE LAW IS ALL WE HAVE.
LAWS ARE DESIGNED TO PROTECT THE
WEAK, NOT THE STRONG.
AT THE MOMENT, THE PEOPLE
LEADING THIS REVOLUTION AGAINST
OUR SYSTEM ARE STRONG.
THAT’S WHY THEY ARE TRYING TO
SUBVERT OUR LAWS PAID IF THEY
SUCCEED, THERE WILL BE NOTHING
TO PROTECT THE REST OF US IN
THIS COUNTRY.
WE CANNOT LET THEM DO THAT.
IN THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA,